[Musique]
le secrétaire général du parti
progressiste martiniquais est avec nous
au lendemain de la rentrée des
progressistes et hier soir françois bon
jour johnny hazzard bonjour bonjour à
toute la martinique alfred marie jeanne
claude lise yan monplaisir et miguel
laventure sont des criminels politiques
hauteur de la souffrance d'une
martinique qui va mal une population qui
souffre parole hier soir de serge
letchimy particulièrement remontée des
criminels politiques johnny jarre se
sont pas des mots qui sont trop fort
goûté la situation la martinique est
grave c'est surtout ce qu'il faut
retenir le peuple est en train de
souffrir
la dictature et la terreur se sont
installés en martinique
les gens ont peur de s'exprimer la
liberté de pensée est atteinte à la
dignité le respect des gens donc on ne
peut que traduire la réalité de ce qui
se passe et nous mais des responsables
qui aujourd'hui sont complices de ce qui
a trait s'est passé et le parti
progressiste martiniquais justement il
le seul à s'exprimer clairement pour que
le respect des libertés celle de pensais
pas que je serais toujours votre part
là-dessus justement lorsque vous dites
qu'il n'ya que le parti progressiste
martiniquais à le dénoncer on a entendu
des associations a entendu des
organisations syndicales on a entendu
des des socioprofessionnels dire que des
choses qui ne vont pas vous avez entendu
très peu d'associations très peu
d'organisations syndicales et surtout
sur des sujets très précis mais la
situation est beaucoup plus grave que ce
que l'on imagine il ya un risque
aujourd'hui de crise institutionnelle
grave
vous avez d'un côté le président du
conseil exécutif avec tous les pouvoirs
et un budget de près de 1 milliard 200
millions d'euros
d'un autre côté vous avez un président
de l'assemblée aujourd'hui qui dirige
une assemblée mais qui a certes eu le
courage politique à la dernière plénière
justement de vouloir ne pas se laisser
faire par un conseiller existe un
président du conseil exécutif totalement
dans la dictature et dans l'imposition
et vous avez un troisième groupe
il faut le dire parce que on parle d'un
certain député du sud qui est simple
conseiller de l'assemblée non il est
président du groupe de la majorité
legrand semble époux bas payés en chance
qu'ils votent toutes les décisions du
conseil exécutif à la 7e donc il y a
aujourd'hui une forme de cocktail
explosif
et quand je dis que nous disons qu'il
faut pouvoir s'exprime
et c'est que c'est un combat par exemple
la dernière fois que l'organisation
syndicale puisse simplement donner la
parole à des hommes et des femmes qui
ont perdu leur travail sans comprendre
les raisons pour lesquelles ça s'est
produit
et ce n'est qu'un qu'une illustration de
ce qui se passe depuis trois années
des complices politique à dire ces
rejets chimiques il savait ce qu'il
faisait qui connaissait le caractère
d'alfred marie-jeanne au moment de
l'alliance de 2015 et qui ferait
semblant d'être des victimes d'un homme
que serge letchimy présente comme un
dictateur écoutez je pense que tout le
monde s'arrête et particulièrement eux
qui sont des aînés politiques qui ont
donc une expérience qui se connaissent
depuis des dizaines d'années donc
effectivement vous savez bien que comme
moi l'association des contraires ne peut
pas tenir
vous savez vous pouvez mettre l'eau et
l'huile dans un même vol
mais ça ne va jamais se rassembler et
donc cette unité d'affichage cette
manipulation qui soit met en place
aujourd'hui cette désinformation
cette démagogie ce populisme qui
démoralise le peuple il faut lutter
contre donc ce serait bien qu'on se
rassemble autour de vraies idées et que
le combat idéologique des valeurs des
idées et des hommes prennent le dessus
sur des camps politiques de place et de
position pas ça c'est ce qui est en
train de se traduit aujourd'hui celui là
veut prendre la place de l'autre en tant
que président de l'assemblée celui à
venir
mais j'ai vite mais écoutez la situation
est claire été détruits en sus aux
autres l'écoutent et la situation est
claire aujourd'hui à la guerre peu
importe qui dirige du groupe
c'est la même politique qui est menée
avec la complicité des autres qui
soutiennent puisqu'ils votent
véritablement tout ce qui se met en
place
sauf que ça ne se fait pas dans
l'intérêt du peuple martiniquais c'est
ça le grand danger
vous dites que la martinique doit faire
face à une équipe dirigeante c'est ce
que vous avez dit hier soir en proie à
des divisions à l'état qui ne connaît
plus que son interlocuteur préfet qu'il
dirige des affaires du pays et un
président de la république et d'une main
d'homme qui reprend tout aussi vite et
plus fort mais nous avons une politique
ultralibérale aujourd'hui du président
de la république et du gouvernement qui
se voit quand on voit aujourd'hui la
chute du nombre de contrats aidés
l'offre de soins qui est moins bonne en
martinique qu'en france quand on voit
véritablement qu'il y à une diminution
importante une faiblesse de
l'investissement public en martinique de
l'état mais aussi des collectivités par
rapport à la france hexagonale
quand on voit la cherté de la vie toutes
les problématiques qui se posent et
quand on voit là la collectivité majeur
qu'est la collectivité territoriale de
mathilde de martinique pardon qui avait
pour mission qui a pour mission du
saumon le servir le peuple de mettre en
place un projet de développement
on se rencontre aujourd'hui et bien
finalement la seule personne qui
aujourd'hui travaillent et qui utilise
toutes les responsabilités ne sont pas
les martiniquais eux mêmes c'est un
préfet qui sort qui doit fonctionnaires
d'état aux fonctionnaires d'état qui
agit pour le compte de l'état par
rapport à la situation de l'état
néanmoins qui ne respectent plus afin
néanmoins parce qu'il n'a pas
d'interlocuteur en face puisque la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
grc problèmes en interne cette situation
est intenable alors que la collectivité
devrait être motrices en matière de
développement et le projet alors il faut
réveiller les consciences il appartient
à ensemble pour une martinique nouvelle
se mobiliser dès aujourd'hui des
municipales pour mieux reprendre la ctm
en 2021 si c'était simple le mot d'ordre
dire soit le modèle c'est l'unité le
rassemblement aujourd'hui face à la
lutte contre cette dictature cette
théorie qui s'installe louis donc il
faut se rassembler ce matin j'ai signé
au chaud c est pour ça qu c des
martiniquais à préciser les modiques
tateurs terreur ça fait pas too much jeu
reprend une formule d écouter les faits
sont là sont têtus c'est un constat et
nous recevons de plus en plus de
citoyens dans nos permanences au
quotidien que nous rencontrons qui qu'a
dit nous pas là jay moule pas mon lit
vous êtes la bouche de ceux qui n'ont
point de bouche donc parler en notre nom
et il faut avoir ce courage politique de
le faire et ce que nous regrettons
aujourd'hui justement ce que nous sommes
pas assez nombreux pour dénoncer mais
aussi pour offrir des perspectives à soi
l'objectif n'est pas simplement une
réservation vous êtes la seule
alternative aujourd'hui le fait voyager
au pmn il faut rester dans l'humilité
il faut rester dans l'unité dans la
modestie faut travailler pour le peuple
mais le ppm et européennes m aujourd'hui
doit être une alternative sera une
alternative et est une alternative
présente quand on regarde aujourd'hui
nos interventions çà de l'assemblée nous
sommes sous les politiques publiques
nous sommes sur l'intérêt du peuple et
nous sommes sur la volonté de projeter
la martinique
venir ça veut dire johnny jarre que va
faire quand même un peu de de
rétropédalage là en décembre 2015 le
grand semblait houba payant chance l'a
emporté c'est aussi parce que le pml a
perdu est ce que vous êtes remis en
question est aujourd'hui dans le mode
opératoire et proposer quelque chose de
nouveau pour repartir à la conquête de
écoutez la remise en question a été
totale en tout cas au sein du parti
progressiste martiniquais mais également
celle de l'alliance
je rappelle que les deux sont en
reconstruction quand vous vivez ce genre
de situation qui est une situation
puis au moment démocratique dans le sens
où c'est le peuple qui a choisi donc il
faut accepter de se remettre en question
et de se regarder en face
oui ce travail-là haïti fait le parti
progressiste martiniquais est renouvelée
au niveau du comité national à plus de
80% beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup de
femmes
il faut préparer la transmission et la
relève et au niveau de pmn il y à une
reconstruction qui est en cours qui se
met en place avec certainement des
départs ça ça même les organisations
parce qu'il faut un socle idéologique et
de valeurs minimum silva leur geste
rassemblé quelle valeur ce socle pas ce
qui c'est ce qui est en train de se
passer au sein du groupe les papillons
chaud ça peut arriver de mieux au niveau
de paix est même si quand même une
coalition de plusieurs petits mouvements
non parce que nous sommes pas simplement
sur de la gestion pure et simple de la
trésorerie qui arrive de l'argent public
et des dépenses qui y est ils sont
affirme nous sommes sur un vrai projet
de rassemblement d'unité de construction
de la personnalité collective
martiniquaise dans le respect de la
dignité et du respect et dans l'éveil
des consciences
nous sommes là l'idéologie césairienne
et des valeurs cia de l'humanisme donc
le l'homme au centre de tout ce que nous
faisons donc le socle il doit être
d'abord idéologique de base donc la
responsabilité locale pour avoir les
propres levier de développement tout en
étant français mais en étant aussi de
bons martinique et ensuite le socle des
valeurs sur la question de l'humanisme
sur la question de la solidarité de
fiers d'être français
écoutez on a de quoi être fier d'être
français mais nous sommes aussi très
fier d'être martiniquais mais aussi
d'être caribéen
il est aussi d'être européen donc multi
multi que ce multiculturalisme
aujourd'hui c'est nous même à faire
sourire de qu'on entend du niger ce
matin dans ce sens fait dire qu'on est
fier d'être français et qu'on entend du
servette lumière dire qu'on est fier
d'être français alors qu'on apprenait
l'autonomie pas du tout mais c'est bien
ça c'est que il faut qu'on vous explique
à nouveau
elle est même invité cet événement pour
qu'on vous explique que l'autonomie ses
alliés le double souci à la fois d'être
français mais aussi d'être de bons mardi
hockey et ça c'est fondamental dont on
parlait de socle minimum idéologie
idéologique pardon le socle minimum de
valeurs mais aussi le socle de projet
puisqu'il faut se projeter ensemble et
pas tout seul arudy ajar l'éveil des
consciences la conscientisation se
mettre ensemble dès aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir préparer les prochaines
échéances électorales
on l'a bien entendu ça y est ce qu'on
vous a reproché en décembre 2015
c'est surtout de ne pas avoir su gérer
chaque fois qu'il ya quelqu'un de pmn du
ppm quelque part il ya des petits soucis
financiers est-ce que ça est ce que ça
vous allez savoir expliquer aux
martiniquais que je pouvais de très bons
gestionnaires aussi mais je ne vois pas
en quoi ce que vous dites je ne
comprends pas du tout très honnêtement
la notion d'être de bon gestionnaire
aujourd'hui elle est affirmé et de
toutes les façons si vous faites
référence
il ya le rapport de la chambre régionale
des comptes qui éclaire donc là c'est
président de région le pmn le parti
progressiste martiniquais nous sommes de
bons gestionnaires c'est bien pour cela
que nous avons un certain nombre de
communes qui sont aujourd'hui dans la
confiance du peuple parce que je
rappelle plein d'élus est un élu pour un
temps et qu'il est élu par le peuple
donc il a des comptes à rendre au peuple
et donc par conséquent et nous dit ce
que la question de les laisser la route
et que nous ne démocratie salariés
devrait alors pas du tout mais il faut
investir
comment voulez-vous pouvoir récolter de
la richesse si vous n'investissez pas
dans le pays vous ne pouvez pas utiliser
uniquement le stock que vous avez un
dépôt il faut créer de la richesse
puisque de toutes les façons l'état
diminue sa solidarité vis-à-vis de la
martinique ne nous devons être sûrs de
notre propre développement et j'ai une
pop richesses naturelles dans un
environnement cordiale caribéens et
pouvoir utiliser notre écologie nous
ressources natuelles notre biodiversité
un nouveau modèle économique qui nous
permettrait de nous projeter vers
l'avenir et de créer non seulement les
ressources financières suffisantes que
les collectivités puissent investir dans
ce pays et sommait du bon grain libérer
l'initiative et que la collectivité
servent de d'éléments institutionnels
moteur merci est révélateur merci johnny
nageurs secrétaire général du parti
progressiste martiniquais merci
d'augmenter dans son caddie
bonne journée merci merci à toute la
martinique et bonne journée
[Musique]